leverage is critical you know I get so
much done cuz I don't just get it done I
know the outcome I know the purpose and
I look for leverage leverage is
different than delegation what's problem
with delegation delegation is you of all
that needs to be done so you give it to
someone else and you tell what needs to
be done and when they don't do it you're
pissed off leverage says I can move the
biggest Boulder in the world with a
little bit of effort if I get something
I can do it with but I'm still part of
it so leveraging this if I'm gonna
leverage something here with Tom I'm
gonna make sure Tom understands the what
the outcome I wanna make sure Tom
understands the the purpose the why and
the action and if I'm really productive
my productivity should enhance the world
and if there's anything you hate to do
it's because you're either ineffective
at it or you don't think it's very
important but it is urgent so you hire
somebody for those things and ideally
somebody who loves that job you're never
gonna grow when your time is eaten up
for activities that aren't that
important activity without high levels
of purpose is the drain of your fortune
do it now if you can't get it all now to
a part of it now leverage is power
leverage is ultimate power how many of
you have things when you want to achieve
them and this part of your voice goes oh
it's not gonna happen or forget it I'm
gonna go to voices sometimes interrupts
that good pattern I was driving a 1968
Volkswagen I had earned it $40 a week as
a janitor I changed my mindset God's
about this circulating in my life as
well flows to me an avalanche is of
abundance all my needs desires and goals
are met instantaneously by infinite
intelligence and I would imagine the
abundance of my life and I would feel so
grateful and you're like one for making
$38,000 a year to make a million dollars
a year and one year you just watched two
amazing clips from Tony Robbins
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]